on the cognition side is where the leap
seems to happen with humans that it does
seem more kind of special and that's a
really interesting question when
thinking about alien life or if there's
other intelligent alien civilizations
out there it's how special is this leap
so one special thing seems to be the
origin of life itself however you define
that there's a gray area and the other
leap this is a very biased perspective
of a human is the
the origin of intelligence and again
from an engineering perspective it's a
difficult question to ask an important
one
is uh how difficult does that leap how
special were humans did uh did a
monolith come down did aliens bring down
a monolith did some Apes had to touch a
monolith but to get it I feel a lot like
dark Descartes uh you know idea right
exactly I it's but it just seems that it
seems one heck of a leap yeah to get to
this level of intelligence yeah and you
know so Chomsky um
uh argued
um
that you know some
uh
genetic fluke occurred a hundred
thousand years ago and you know just
happened that some
human some hominin
predecessor of current humans had this
one genetic tweak that resulted in
language yeah and language then provided
this
special thing that separates us from all
other animals
um
I'm
I think there's a lot of Truth to the
value and importance of language
but I think it comes along with
um the evolution of a lot of other
related things related to sociality and
mutual engagement with others
and um
establishment of um
I don't know rich
mechanisms for
organizing an understanding of the world
which language then plugs into right so
it's uh language is a tool that allows
you to do this kind of collective
intelligence and whatever is at the core
of
the thing that allows for this
collective intelligence is the main
thing and it's interesting to think
about that one fluke
one mutation could lead to the like the
the first crack open opening of the door
to human intelligence like all it takes
is one like Evolution just kind of opens
the door a little bit and then the time
and selection takes care of the rest
you know there's so many fascinating
aspects to these kinds of things so
we think of evolution as continuous
right we think oh yes okay over
500 million years there could have been
this
you know relatively continuous uh
changes and
um
but that's not what
anthropologists evolutionary biologists
found from the fossil record they found
you know
hundreds of years of hundreds of
millions of years of stasis yeah and
then you know suddenly a change occurs
well suddenly on that scale is a million
years or something but but or even 10
million years but
but um the concept of punctuated
equilibrium was a very important Concept
in evolutionary biology
uh and uh that
also feels somehow right about
you know the stages of our mental
abilities we we seem to have a certain
kind of mindset at a certain age and
then
at another
age we like look at that four-year-old
and say oh my God how could they have
thought that way so Piaget was known for
this kind of stage theory of Child
Development right and you'll look at it
closely and suddenly those stages are so
discreet and the transitions but the
difference between the four-year-old and
the seven-year-old is profound and
that's another thing that's always
interested me is how we
something happens over the course of
several years of experience where at
some point we reached the point where
something like an Insider a transition
or a new stage of development occurs and
uh
you know these kinds of things can be
understood
um
in complex systems research and so um
evolutionary biology developmental
biology
um
cognitive development are all things
that have been approached in this kind
of way yeah
just like you said I find both
fascinating those early years of human
life but also the early like minutes
days of from the embryonic development
to like how from embryos you get like
the brain that development
again from the engineering perspective
is fascinating so it's not so the early
um when you deploy the brain to the
human world and it gets to explore that
world and learn that's fascinating but
just like the Assembly of the mechanism
that is capable of learning that's like
amazing the stuff they're doing with
like brain organoids where you can build
many brains and study that
um self-assembly of a mechanism from
like the DNA material that that's like
what the heck you have literally like
biological programs that just generate a
system this mushy thing that's able to
be robust and learn in a very
unpredictable world and learn seemingly
arbitrary things or like
a very large number of things that I'll
enable survival yeah ultimately
um
that is a very important part of the
whole process of you know understanding
this sort of
emergence of Mind from brain kind of
kind of thing and the whole thing seems
to be pretty continuous